With all the rewrites, test screenings, and
last-minute edits, it's amazing that any film
gets made at all.
But every so often, everything lines up just
perfectly.
Bring together the right screenplay with the
right director, cast, and crew, and you just
might get a perfect film.
These movies are few and far between, but
when they come along, you know right away
you've found a flawless film.
Mulholland Drive
Explaining the plot of Mulholland Drive is
like trying to describe a deep and disturbing
dream; it leaves you emotional and confused
in equal measure.
Director David Lynch uses the film to explore
the darker aspects of Hollywood and how often
our grand goals give way to despair.
While you're sifting through all this dream
logic, Lynch keeps you glued to the screen
with mesmerizing sequences like Naomi Watts'
Betty turning standard movie audition dialogue
into something genuinely chilling:
"You're playing a dangerous game here.
If you're trying to blackmail me, it's not
going to work.
It's no wonder that in 2016, the BBC named
this surrealist masterpiece the greatest film
of the 21st century.
"Il n'est pas d'orchestra.
It.
Is.
An illusion.
Manchester by the Sea
Written and directed by Kenneth Lonergan,
Manchester by the Sea tells the story of Lee
Chandler, an irritable janitor forced to return
to his hometown to look after his nephew following
the loss of his brother.
We don't want to give away too much of the
plot, but there's a reason that going home
is the last thing Lee wants to do.
Every sight and sound reminds him of something
truly tragic that happened years ago, an event
so horrible that he might never recover.
Casey Affleck won an Oscar for his performance
as Lee, as did Lonergan for Best Original
Screenplay, and the two truly deserved their
accolades.
Every gesture Affleck makes, every line he
doesn't say, aches with pain.
And while the film is full of uncomfortably
comic moments, Manchester by the Sea grapples
with grief in a way that most movies wouldn't
dare.
It's a beautifully brutal film about living
with pain forever.
The Witch
One of the most disturbing horror movies in
recent memory, The Witch tells the story of
a Puritan family fighting for their lives
when a supernatural force attacks their isolated
farmhouse.
Director Robert Eggers spent four years studying
the Puritan lifestyle and reading firsthand
accounts of demonic possession in order to
write the script as accurately as possible.
He also got super involved when it came to
sets and props: the costumes were hand-sewn,
and the furniture was built just like the
Puritans used to do it.
Eggers wanted everything perfect, and it certainly
shows in the actual movie; by paying so much
attention to the little details in every scene,
the film fully immerses viewers in the nightmarish
setting.
Even besides all the props and research, Eggers
managed to get incredible performances from
the child actors, and somehow found the scariest
goat to ever put on film.
"Black Phillip, antlers on his head! Black Phillip, Black Phillip..."
And if a movie can make livestock scary, you
know you've got an instant horror classic
on your hands.
The Grand Budapest Hotel
In retrospect, it seems like Wes Anderson's
entire career was building up to The Grand
Budapest Hotel.
It's the perfect blend of all things Anderson,
from his meticulous world-building and witty
dialogue to the melancholy air that hovers
over all of his films.
The plot involves a lobby boy named Zero,
played by Tony Revolori, who comes to work
for the flamboyant and foul-mouthed Monsieur
Gustave at the Grand Budapest Hotel.
As with most Anderson movies, a plot summary
doesn't capture the unique wit and unmistakable
cinematography that makes Grand Budapest so
appealing.
"What else?"
"Zero.
Confused."
Confused, indeed.
The plot thickens, as they say.
Why, by the way, is it a soup metaphor?"
With a brilliant lead performance from Ralph
Fiennes as Gustave, The Grand Budapest Hotel
is a fanciful breath of fresh air.
It's proof that style and substance can go
hand-in-hand.
Creed
Ryan Coogler's Creed isn't just a great Rocky
sequel, it's a great movie all on its own.
Michael B. Jordan puts in a jaw-dropping performance
as Adonis Creed, the son of the late great
champ Apollo Creed.
Adonis is eager to fight and desperate to
prove himself, and he turns to the legendary
Rocky Balboa for help.
As Adonis boxes his way to a title shot, director
Ryan Coogler builds on the franchise mythology
in exciting ways.
And then there's the moment when Adonis goes
to battle the champ, and the famous Rocky
theme starts playing in the greatest nostalgia-fueled
moment of the last 20 years.
Jordan is on his A-game here, giving us a
hero who's not a Rocky Balboa clone but a
young man with his own issues and dreams.
Creed was an underdog movie that defied everyone's
expectations, and it can hold its own as one
of the greatest sequels of all time.
Silence
In 1988, Martin Scorsese took a new look at
the Gospels with The Last Temptation of Christ,
and nearly 30 years later, Scorsese returned
to religion with Silence, a movie about a
man's crisis of faith when it seems he's been
forsaken by God.
The plot involves two Jesuit priests played
by Andrew Garfield and Adam Driver, who sneak
into Japan to find a missing mentor who has
supposedly abandoned his faith.
When Garfield's priest is captured, he finds
himself confronted with a difficult decision:
Recant his faith and risk damnation, or watch
as his fellow Christians are tortured to death.
"Think of the suffering you have inflicted
on these people, all because of your selfish
dream of a Christian Japan."
Silence is beautifully shot by Rodrigo Prieto,
who contrasts the beauty of Japan with the
brutality of crucified men drowning in the
sea.
Ultimately, Silence explores the nature of
faith: how it can inspire both hope and cruelty,
how it can rip apart lives and give others
the strength to soldier on.
Get Out
As Jordan Peele famously said on Colbert Report
The Late Show, Get Out is a documentary.
"You've submitted this to the Golden Globes
as a comedy."
"I submitted it as a documentary."
It's a fictional version of the horrors black
people experience every day in America.
The story follows a young black photographer
named Chris, played wonderfully by Daniel
Kaluuya who goes to meet his white girlfriend's
family.
From the moment he shows up at their estate,
everything seems off, and it's hard to tell
if it's casual racism or something more overtly
sinister.
This is Peele's directorial debut, but he
shows himself to be a master at drawing out
the tension until everything explodes in a
bloody mess of jiu-jitsu, tea cups, and deer
antlers.
Although Peele is best-known for his comedic
work on Key and Peele, Get Out shows that
he's even better at terrifying an audience
than he was at making people laugh.
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
Michel Gondry is a director known for his
whimsical imagination.
Charlie Kaufman is a screenwriter known for
his witty pessimism.
When the two combined their cinematic powers
for Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind,
they created an all-time great romance that
took a long, hard look at the ugly side of
love and how relationships actually work.
"I've been thinking lately of how I was before
and how I am now and it's like he changed
me.
I feel like I'm always pissy now.
I don't like myself when I'm with him, I don't
like myself anymore."
This inventive romance skips through time
and memories, as Jim Carrey's Joel re-experiences
the memories of his failed relationship.
The film doesn't ignore the pain and pitfalls
of making a relationship work, and by examining
the different stages of romance, this is a
movie that changes and grows with each and
every viewing.
"This is it Joel.
It's going to be gone soon."
"I know."